foreign
Mark Norman made stand-up career history
this morning with the release of his
first full-length Netflix special Soup
To Nuts and yesterday we had the
pleasure of sitting down with Mark for a
quick interview surrounding his massive
Netflix debut Mark Norman thank you so
much for being here we're recording this
about eight hours before soups and nuts
officially drops on Netflix so what does
that feel like sitting around today I
know you're on the road you're busy but
you're waiting for this massive video to
come out that you've put years of work
into now it's just kind of all out of
your hands so what does that feel like
leading up to the premiere later tonight
oh well yeah
tomorrow and
I pr I hired a publicist he's charging
me a million dollars I've done so many
podcasts and interviews I'm on the
toilet right now because I'm out of time
I am I'm at a hotel I'm in a [__] box
Hotel in Lancaster my key didn't work so
I went to the front desk and he was like
oh you're supposed to be checked out
it's 4 P.M so now he's he's waiting
outside my door and I was like I just
got to take a [__] so he's letting me
[__] and pack and then I gotta go find
somewhere to shower but this is the road
folks I saw you mention on Chrissy chaos
that Netflix gives you like a certain
amount of money basically and then you
have to decide how much to spend on
producing the special then how much to
keep is that kind of right yeah yeah
it's kind of a [__] deal but they
they're smart businessmen because they
know we want to be on Netflix so they
give you a couple a couple bucks you
gotta shoot it edit it promote it all
the stuff they used to do
uh and then you own it in two years
that's the big catch so that's pretty
good yeah because I was thinking based
on what you see in podcasts and things
it seems like the ongoing joke about you
amongst your peers is that your very
money conscious I think Shane Gillis was
the one talking about you eating like
the random Leftovers on the Tuesdays
with stories live so is it hard for you
to make these huge financial decisions
for something like that's so expensive
like producing a Netflix quality special
or was this just different than your
personal life you just gotta get it done
well that's a great question there fatty
but the real problem is I'm cool with
buying big I bought a brownstone in
Brooklyn I bought a BMW a vintage car
which was a huge uh money suck but I'm
not good at buying stuff for me like a
smoothie or a new underwear that makes
sense but the special it's a big thing
so yeah I can Splurge I went all out
because I want I want it to be good you
know it's going to last forever you put
a lot of work into it so yeah I really
went I went swung for the fences on that
that makes sense it seems like comedians
have different experiences working with
like these big streamers obviously like
Andrew Schultz had the story about
buying his back and you're someone who
typically works with darker jokes and
darker topics so was there anything that
Netflix had a problem with or were they
just like the keys are in your hands I
couldn't believe it I think maybe like a
Dave Chappelle or somebody opened the
door for uh just saying crazy [__] or
Ricky Gervais maybe they were cool I got
Holocaust Down syndrome you know fat
jokes trans jokes you name it and they
were the only thing they said was I
wouldn't do covet stuff just because
it's it's passed yeah it's out of date
so I was like great because it's been a
little bit between your last special out
to lunch and this one right about three
years I think about three years but I
did do a half hour for Netflix in
between there so don't forget that yeah
who's counting your last special on
YouTube is currently at around 12
million views you're barely early on the
YouTube wave for comedians putting on
full specials to their own channels was
there any hesitancy to go with Netflix
this time after seeing just how
perfectly it worked on YouTube last time
or was it always a goal to have a full
length 50-minute special hour special on
Netflix regardless another great
question Boy you know you know your
comedy Biz that's right um yeah it's
great it's great having a guy on the
other side because all the comedians
know all this [__] then you can't talk
to anybody about it who's not a comedian
but you're you're a nerd like us
basically I love YouTube YouTube is
great it's great for comedy these
Gatekeepers stuck you know they're it's
a business at the end of the day so they
they got no uh balls they don't want to
take a risk on a guy or a gal or a
non-binary but I think I got the YouTube
crowd I feel like I won that fight and
then I'm like let me see if I can win
the Netflix crowd and alone in two years
anyway so I can just put it on YouTube
so it's a win-win and you get a couple
bucks yeah so I figure hey let's mix it
up and I get it back anyway that makes a
lot of sense that seems awesome okay
last question this is kind of an inside
nerdy YouTube question but I noticed
that you changed your profile picture
from the out to lunch cover photo to the
new soups and nuts cover photo of the
Year
nuts Two Nuts soups To Nuts there we go
should we expect that to be the new
picture for the next three years on the
Mark Norman YouTube channel well I don't
know I mean who knows what the next
thing will be and I'll change it then I
I try not to I never know how to do any
of that stuff the uh my publicist or my
manager will do all that I'll just give
them the password and tell them you do
it I'll probably just end up keeping it
up because I'm a lazy douche so yeah
that'll be up till the next thing I
produce awesome well thank you so much
for your time today thank you for
hopping on the channel and talking with
us is here and everyone this comes out
Tuesday so this is the same day that you
can go check out Mark's new special on
Netflix right now thank you again mark
thank you sir and uh keep doing what
you're doing we all we all like it and
uh I'm gay
appreciate it thanks Fred Mark Norman's
partner in crime Joe list has a brand
new short film premiering this Tuesday
in New York City that will also be
uploaded to YouTube following their
theater debut Joe has been part of
numerous high quality small films over
the past few years and based on the
trailer this one looks just as good
that's a five man what do you got
arthritis in your face or what no my
feet
yo what's up man sick I'm on antibiotic
you need to kick this [__] out
though yo I have alcohol in it it's got
like less than one percent alcohol you
be [__] bisexual it means you have
sex with two people two people it's two
genders you dum-dums is still two people
over this film more in depth the next
video but if you're watching this right
now go check out got punch if you want
to support comedians making independent
projects guest spots from last week The
Joe Rogan Experience had on Duncan
Trussell and Tony Woods Jason Alice was
on are you garbage why Mage talked with
Robert Eiler Kyle canine was a guest on
Whiskey ginger kill Tony this week was
with Adam Ray and Rich Voss two bears
one cave was Burton Tom and Burton
flagrant did not have a guest Brian
Callan was the guest on the Harland
Highway Ian Lara was on we might be
drunk and Andrew Santino went on stavy's
world there's no woman on earth who when
she sits down blank canvas and says
describe your perfect man there is not
one that describes me
how about sweet thoughtful funny no no
all those things but if in a perfect
world yeah but nobody's drawing their
perfect person that doesn't exist but
that's otherwise no men would never get
married sure but no one picks us yeah
we're we're we're
um we're we're you know like a colander
for you know like a like a gold sifter
it's like ooh yeah you're gonna yeah
you're yeah you're gonna have to like
let some things go at some point alcohol
is um all right let that go your money
yeah let that go four night skins
yeah getting your credit card yeah
playing video games till 2 30 in the
morning and stuff like it's like eating
when you should and eating stuff you
shouldn't yep something [__] up [__]
to my parents yeah right right right
yeah arguing with my dad about the Bud
Light campaign
agreeing with your dad on the bus
this past weekend with the Yvonne talked
with Jim Gaffigan Mark Norman was guest
on Percy chaos Mark was also the guest
on taste buds where they battled dark
meat vs Lightning Kirk Fox was on the
Honeydew Duncan Trussell was on first
date Esther povitzky went on take your
shoes off Being Ian with Jordan did not
have a guest Sean Patton was on you know
what dude Ike baronholtz was on
tigerbelly Pauly Shore went on this
[__] podcast as far as new stand-up
specials go They're either out right now
or coming out soon obviously we've
talked about it all episode Mark
Norman's debut Netflix special Soup To
Nuts is out right now definitely go
check that out if you're a fan of great
comedy and great comedians other
specials out on YouTube right now Mark
Ellis alive and well Trey Crowder damn
boy and Jeffrey asmus the only funny
white man are all really good specials
that are definitely worth the watch
that's funny you people drink here
people really people don't drink on the
East Coast you know that like people
here if you're not drunk it's like court
ordered and it's like you had to stop
you're like I can't pregame Church judge
put a chip in my liver yeah
also huge shout out to Mark Norman for
coming on the show once again it's
always super cool getting to interview
someone like Mark Norman for these
videos which obviously would not be
possible without subscribers like you
guys so seriously thank you so much for
supporting joke World we're gonna keep
trying to do our part and deliver the
best possible videos about the comedy
world to you guys we got a few more
coming out this week so keep your eyes
peeled Mark Norman try not to laugh
coming out this Thursday put your post
notifications on thank you guys so much
again thank you Mark again and thanks
for watching I said thanks too many
times huh
at joke world
and the world is wrld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out